deutschlandweit ist der Polizeifunk
ausgefallen das ist eine mega Panne
passiert Mittwochnacht in ganz
Deutschland da konnte kein Streifenwagen
mehr erreicht werden kein Rettungswagen
keine Feuerwehr und das mehr als eine
Viertelstunde lang aber wie konnte das
bitteschön passieren diese Panne unsere
BILD-Reporter haben das recherchiert
ein Ausfall dieser Dimension ist
einmalig 17 Minuten ist wohl kein
Polizist und kein Feuerwehrmann in
Deutschland mehr über den Digitalfunk zu
erreichen so können die Einsatzzentralen
weder Polizisten noch Rettungskräfte zu
Hilfe suchenden schicken auch laufende
Einsätze können nicht koordiniert werden
das ist natürlich der Super-GAU für die
Polizei den Kommunikation ist das Top
Handwerkzeug der Polizei untereinander
und wenn Polizei auch improvisieren kann
geht das nur für einige Zeit
glücklicherweise war es 2 Uhr nachts da
ist jetzt nicht so eine
spitzeneinsatzzeit an einem Nachmittag
im Berufsverkehr möchte ich mir das
nicht vorstellen der Ausfall besteht
wohl bundesweit zu unterschiedlichen
Zeiten unterschiedlich lang in Hamburg
dauert der Ausfall 17 Minuten lang
es waren angekündigte Arbeiten an der
Netzstruktur und dabei ist etwas
passiert was wir noch nicht wissen was
zu diesem Ausfall führte sagte Polizei
Hamburg
aber nicht nur die Polizei kann nicht
über den Digitalfunk kommunizieren auch
bei der Feuerwehr fällt die
Kommunikation aus um 2 Uhr für 5 Minuten
eine Ewigkeit wenn man auf
lebenswichtige Hilfe wartet der
Digitalfunk der Polizei ist eine lange
Geschichte weit mehr als zwölf Jahre
lang hat man daran gearbeitet Milliarden
investiert und bislang kann Polizei auch
nur miteinander sprechen vielmehr können
wir nicht der Digitalfunk sollte einmal
ganz anders ausgelegt sein das hat etwas
damit zu tun dass die Länder nicht
genügend Geld investieren wollten um
stabile Leitungen zu schaffen denn der
Bund stellt nur das sogenannte Rumpfnetz
zur Verfügung das heißt man muss einfach
mehr Geld ins System stecken die einzige
beruhigende Nachricht in diesen
kommunikationschaos die
einsatzkoordination der Polizei kann auf
sogenannte
mobipol-geräte ausweichen das sind
spezielle Handys die fast jeder Polizist
bei sich führt das ist natürlich nur
eine begrenz wirksamer und eine wirklich
schlechte Lösung denn bei Handys kann
der eine das hören was der andere sagt
aber wir sind auch aus einsatztaktischen
Gründen darauf angewiesen dass
gleichzeitig mehrere Kräfte diese
Informationen bekommen
jetzt muss geklärt werden was genau zu
dem Ausfall geführt hat ein erster
Verdacht liegt auf Wartungsarbeiten die
falsch gelaufen sind es ist aber nicht
der erste Ausfall des digitalfunksystems
für sicherheits- und Rettungskräfte die
lebensrettende Krisenkommunikation kann
auch im Hochwasser 2021 in NRW und in
Rheinland-Pfalz nicht sichergestellt
werden
Stromausfälle sind damals der Grund
dafür wenn der Behördenfunk damals nicht
ausgefallen wäre dann hätten
Menschenleben gerettet werden können
[Musik]